Now for the remaining examples, we're
going to use a P list and a JSON file
that both represent a maze like
the one you've seen in the maze app.
Let's start by peeking at the P list.
At the top level,
it contains a count for
the number of rows, the number
of columns and some cell data.
The cell data is an array, and
if we drop down, we can see that
it contains arrays as well.
And if we click one of the arrays,
it contains more arrays.
Wow.
And if we click one of the arrays,
then we see that we had
these four Boolean values.
And this repeats for every single
one of their innermost arrays.
Now that was pretty ugly to look at.
And it may seem complicated, but
what it's really modeling is a 2D grid.
Each of the innermost arrays describes
a grid cell like the one seen here.
And it tells us if the grid
cell contains a wall or
a path on the top, the right,
the bottom or the left of the cell.
Now let's take a look at this
cell that we've marked in blue.
The first value in the array is true or
yes.
These map very directly so that means
that there should be a wall on the top.
The next value's also true so
that means there should also
be a wall on the right.
The next item we have a no, or a false.
So there's no wall, or we'd say there's
a path on the bottom of this cell.
And the same goes for the left.
Now if you think back to the maze app,
these top, right, bottom and
left represents the walls and the paths
and you can see that more clearly here.
That cell that we were just
looking at is the cell in the top
right hand corner.
And we can see that the top and
right are true.
So we have a wall in the top and right.
But the bottom and the left are false,
so there's a path here.
Now if we go back to the P list file
we'll see that the number of arrays here
matches the number of rows.
So we have five rows.
And then we have one, two,
three, four, five arrays.
And the number of arrays within a row,
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven,
matches the number of columns.
So this P list describes
a five by seven maze.
Now, the JSON file contains
the exact same data, but
it's formatted a little bit differently.
And as we're looking at it here,
it's kind of hard to read.
It's not very pretty.
Now when you're faced with JSON
like this, I'd recommend copy and
pasting it into an online
JSON tool that prettifies it.
And prettify is not a real word.
I mean to say that it formats
the JSON so it's much easier to read.
So we'll go ahead and copy this.
And then this is jsonprettyprint.com.
And we'll paste it in.
And then we'll run.
And that's much better.
So again, if you have some really
complex JSON that's kind of mangled and
you want to spread it out and
make it pretty and easier to read,
I'd recommend using a tool like this.
So now that we have a rough idea
of what this data looks like and
it represents, what can we do with it?
So let's think about how we
would model this in code.
Here's a struct that represents
one of the cells that we saw.
So it's got four Boolean values, true
and false values representing whether
there's a wall or a path for
the top, right, bottom, and left.
And as we saw a second ago, based on the
true and false values in each array for
each grid cell, we could determine
whether there's a wall or a path.
So, these are a couple examples
that give us an idea of
what the grid cell might look like.
So when everything is true, we have
walls on the top, the left, the right,
and the bottom.
When this last Bool value is false,
and that represents the left,
then the left side has a path
while everything else has a wall.
And then if everything is false,
the we have a path that goes to the top,
the left, the right, and the bottom.
So let's imagine that we have this
simplified version of the cell data.
It only has two rows and two columns.
And if we were to go
through each grid cell,
then we would result in a representation
that's something like this.